for now though look the
covet 19 pandemic continues to be a
reality for the nfl all day long every
day we see players added to the covet 19
list there's a very high degree of
transparency as to who's on it it
doesn't mean anyone is having symptoms
it doesn't mean that anyone even has the
virus you can be on the list even if
you've had close contact with someone
who's positive and peter the flaw
continues to be the absence of point of
care testing that's why everyone has to
be so careful because of that 24-hour
lag between sample collection
and test result and in that 24 hours if
you begin shedding virus before you know
you're positive that's how the outbreak
can start and if they could just get to
the point and by they i don't know who
they is they is whoever is out there
making this stuff if they could get to
the point where there is a sufficiently
accurate point of care test so many of
these problems would be gone because you
wouldn't get into the facility until you
test negative every day every day every
day
yeah like that
i saw that hole in the testing right
away
i think everybody did that
basically if you've got to wait up to 24
hours for the result of the test and you
have then spent perhaps the previous 24
hours
not necessarily in close contact there's
a bunch of teams might
that i've i've talked to that are doing
like odd things you know how you have
the uh
you know this thing that says if you're
within close contact for 15 minutes of
anybody who's got the virus
well you know
every nine minutes at the carolina
panthers uh
you know in their meetings
if they are together in any way even
though they're doing an awful lot
virtually every nine minutes a horn
blows and everybody's supposed to get
away from whoever they're around at that
moment and i know that sounds insane but
it's good insurance
for you know to stop hanging around with
anybody because that anybody who knows
could have tested positive sometime that
just isn't known yet
so to me
i think those are the kind of steps you
have to take to make absolutely sure
that nobody transmits it
and the bills yesterday had to send all
of their rookies home after a sufficient
number of them ended up on the covet 19
list you know the rookies and the
quarterbacks are a little bit ahead of
everyone else we're in the first few
days of camp and the veteran players
have to test negatively three times
before they're cleared to get onto the
field the rookies and the quarterbacks
have been there a little bit longer
they're in the building not in buffalo
they were sent home because they want to
get this thing under control they're
doing the virtual meetings not the
in-person meetings to keep guys separate
but this is what we have to worry about
no matter what steps are taken to
ensure that the virus doesn't spread in
the facility it still can especially if
guys are bringing it with them and
that's why john gruden said what he said
peter we're going to play mike tomlin
from yesterday making it crystal clear
that this year
for an nfl player your job definitely
goes home with you and what you do or
don't do once you leave the facility is
a key part of whether or not you're
going to end up being held accountable
here's tomlin from thursday
you guys know i like catch phrases but
what you're talking about is conduct
that is detrimental
and that's a term that's used often in
our business and appropriately so uh
because in this covet environment if
you're not exercising discretion and
being thoughtful about how you move that
conduct is detrimental to your cause and
to ours collectively and so that's the
messaging that i'm delivering to those
guys um you know we got to conduct
ourselves accordingly there's been a lot
of work to position ourselves to be
where we are right now um you know it's
one fail all fail in this environment
and so we're going to continue to
package the messaging that way
and be very transparent it is that it's
conduct detrimental to their efforts and
ours
he's absolutely right peter in many
respects the teams that are best able to
minimize the number of players who are
on the covet 19 list throughout the
course of the season those teams are
going to be more successful because
they're going to have their best players
available to them i mean it's strange to
think that on some sundays
as a practical matter the game is won
before the game even starts because
you're able to put your 22 regulars out
on the field on offense and defense and
the other team may have five six seven
of those guys gone because their players
haven't been as conscientious now the
hope is that everybody will be
conscientious so that there won't be a
team that is completely depleted at any
position group or across the board but
the fewer just like with injuries i mean
this is just a twi you know we see every
year when we look back at the end of the
season the teams that had the fewest
guys on injured reserves the fewest
starters unavailable to them per game
those are the teams that tend to be
successful well you got another twist
this year you have something that isn't
an injury that can make your guys not
available so if you can keep your guys
available you're more likely to be
successful
you know mike i i think dovetailing on
that we're headed into a very
interesting weekend in the nfl not only
because you're going to see more
positive covet tests i'm sure
basically because this is the week that
the players are coming back and it's not
only interesting because teams can
basically start this weekend you know
other than kansas city and houston which
already have they can start doing actual
football stuff after the physicals but i
also think it's interesting because
monday is the deadline for opting out
we've already seen the new york giants
lose their left tackle understandably
nate solder we've already seen the
new england patriots
lose their fifth and sixth starters on
defense so now it's not only free agents
but it's opt-outs and to me
this is a long weekend that's going to
tell the tale a lot about who is going
to contend and who isn't in the nfl in
2020
and peter let me add just a small caveat
to that because
as
of last word when i checked wednesday
night and i tried again last night
because the cba revision has not been
finalized yet the seven day window for
opting out hasn't even opened so if that
agreement is not signed as of this
moment and i have not heard that it is
and i've seen no indication to suggest
that it is and the lawyers had it bogged
down as of wednesday night
today
one week from is the earliest that the
opt-out deadline can come so this is
going to hover once we get into practice
and i like this this is one of the
things i wanted to talk to you about
because sims and i have been addressing
this from time to time you know the nfl
wanted a very early opt-out deadline
they want to know who's in they want to
know who's out well the problem is some
of these guys may need to show up they
may need to look around they may need to
begin to get ensconced in order to have
an idea that gut feeling is this right
for me is this right for my family and
as it stands
you got four extra days now because this
agreement isn't done four extra days for
the players to come to a conclusion an
informed conclusion as to whether opting
out is or isn't the right thing for them
and i just got a general hesitation with
this speak now or forever hold your
piece idea i think there should be more
time for players to make a final
decision and i think there should be an
opportunity like we see in baseball for
a guy to say i was out but you know what
i feel more comfortable now i've paid
attention to what you guys are doing
i've paid attention to what's happening
i want back then yeah
yeah yeah your thoughts on that i think
what is i think what's really
interesting mike is i talked to an agent
yesterday and i asked him about this
uh
about
how many guys he has
who he still thinks might opt out this
is a big agent
and he said as of right now i've got
three who are still considering it
two of whom have told their coach that
they'd let them know by the end of this
weekend
but as as this agent said i found this
very interesting
once players get into the building
and they see their friends and they see
the guys who they're with
they feel more mostly i think and that's
what this agent said especially about
two of his three guys
uh they feel like they really would like
to be there
so he said if they had to make the
decision before they went into the
facility at all you know even just to
take a test
or to be on some virtual meetings
you know they felt like maybe they were
going to opt out and this agent said if
i had to guess now i'd say at least two
of my three guys
are going to go back because the juices
have started flowing about playing
football again and obviously making
money again
at a minimum i'd like to see the players
have until two or three days after the
fully padded practices begin in the
middle of august because
it's one thing to walk into the facility
and see how everything is spaced out and
see everyone with masks on and the
contact tracing devices they have and
everyone's in the meeting rooms far
enough apart to the extent they even do
the meetings in meeting rooms this year
i'd want to see how a guy feels and if i
was one of the players i'd want to see
how i feel after being out there in
close quarters on a football field when
you're in a full 11 on 11 session a lot
of these practices will be more intense
than in other training camps peter
because they have to take the pre-season
the opportunity to separate the wheat
from the chaff in the preseason and jam
it into training camp and coaches have
said they're going to have more
competitive periods during practice i'd
want to know how i feel after being you
know in a pile up having a guy right
across from me just to do am i
comfortable in that setting that that
this is going to work and and maybe give
it a couple days to see if there's a
little mini outbreak once they start
having those 11 on 11 practices i just
wish guys had more time i understand why
the league wants to know who's in and
who's out but what you may be doing by
having a deadline so early you may be
getting some guys to opt out who
otherwise would have stuck around if
they had more time to get to that level
of comfort that you're talking about
well the problem that i see with that is
not only would the coaches
really not want that obviously because
they have enough adjustments to make on
the fly
you know to have two or three starters
leave on
let's say august 21st that'd be pretty
tough you know basically a week and a
half before you gotta cut your roster
two weeks before you cut your roster
but the other problem that i would see
with that and it's not a huge problem i
think the nfl wants
you know they don't want the reason i
think that they're
basically cutting down to 80 you know on
august 16th and most teams have already
cut to 80 we know that
but not all yet
i think the reason why they would like
to have more you know
lesser numbers in camp is it's less of a
chance to transmit the disease
um so
if they did that mike i think they would
probably want to say that we're going to
give you like a 10-day extension on
being able to have 80 guys in training
camp uh because or or as many guys in
training camp as you want because
you basically now if you were going to
extend that deadline you're really
making it tough on the coaches to make
sure that they have all alternatives
at their disposal
and peter as you were explaining that
it made me think of one specific team
last year
that had to deal with the sudden
disappearance of a very key player the
andrew luck retirement that happened
that last weekend in august and and and
here's the thing depending upon a
player's contractual situation if you
don't owe significant signing bonus
money to the team depending upon what
your individual deal is and there's a
significant percentage of players who
don't have that anchor that requirement
that they have to pay back money there
are guys who are operating under one
year contract maybe they didn't get a
signing bonus at all or two-year
contracts or or a multi-year deal where
the signing bonus has already been fully
accounted for you can have guys just
retire the opt-out deadline
is separate and apart and i hadn't even
thought of that until just now you could
just have a guy late august say
all things considered i'm retiring i'm
not opting out i'm just retiring which
you're allowed to do it doesn't violate
your contract it doesn't say up for a 50
000 a day fine if you retire the only
issue is you may have to pay back
signing bonus money but that's a
fallback depending upon a guy's contract
and maybe we will see some of that
happen
once we get into
the 11 11 practices or peter once they
have to leave the mini bubble and start
traveling to other cities and staying in
hotels and playing games against
opponents you can have guys decide to
retire during the season
definitely could mike and i that will
not shock me at all uh if that happens
uh because clearly
let's say there's a mini outbreak on a
team
there's a mini outbreak on a team
what do you think that
you know a guy who might have three or
four kids at home what do you think he's
facing when he gets home every day
you know i hate to be dramatic about
this but i won't be surprised if two or
three guys on a team test positive and a
guy goes home
and you know the family makes the
decision listen you go stay in a hotel
for a while
you know and don't come around the
family either that or
you know just
stay stay away from us and you go stay
in the
you know in the den uh and we'll seal it
off or something like that it's you know
there's so many different stories that
we don't know yet that during the season
we're just going to see these things pop
up every day every day
and what you just said peter i think
leads nicely into the next point i want
to make before we do that though some
words from dr alan sills the nfl's chief
medical officer i'm going to be
interviewing him for pftpm coming up in
a few hours but yesterday via the
houston chronicle he said he remains
cautiously optimistic about the season
because we've spent a tremendous amount
of time and energy with these protocols
preparing trying to mitigate risk to the
best that we can at the same time we
have to realize this is going to be hard
this is going to be really hard because
this is a tough opponent
cautiously optimistic i'd like you know
a little bit stronger than that but it's
realistic we don't know optimism with
caution is all you can really do and
peter
one of the things that i still continue
to be fascinated about is whether a
bubble a full bubble like the nba nhl
mls would have worked for the nfl it
probably wouldn't have worked as a full
bubble and it probably wouldn't work now
to pivot to one and say we'll start the
season in november we're gonna find
150 acres or more of land you probably
need more than that to have that many
people and build dormitories and have
enough fields and bring everybody in and
seal it off and even then you can't seal
it off because food is flowing in and
out
set that aside
what about the possibility as you
suggested that may happen on a de facto
basis with a family saying
hey
football playing husband you go stay in
a hotel until further notice what about
localized bubbles where the players do
stay
in a hotel
in a separate facility matt ryan told me
earlier this week they got townhouses
behind their practice facility that they
have divided up for the guys where they
can go in and they have their own
bathroom they have their own changing or
they have their own bed
why not just remove the players from
their homes put them in these hotels put
them in a harder bubble
and uh look it's not going to be easy
you're going to have more guys who will
opt out but you're still going to
eventually have enough players who say
yes i'll do that to play football this
year
that may be the only way to prevent
these outbreaks and i just wonder
whether or not that's something that
should be or is under consideration
well
however whatever way you're talking
about a bubble happening you're talking
about
every nfl player
for the next five months
basically
being apart from
family
uh and
and obviously everybody has credited the
nba and rightfully so but if you think
about the nba
eight of the 30 teams did not go to
orlando so they're not in any bubble
whatsoever
six teams are in a bubble for a month
then they will be eliminated and won't
be in the playoffs so that's half the
players in the league a month or less
and then you have 12 teams 12 more teams
where it's about two months you know the
the the playoff teams
so
basically mike it's the vast majority of
nba players
are from one month to two months away
that's a lot different than five months
it's hard for me to imagine that a
player who has
uh who has four or five kids
uh is going to be able to just disappear
for five months i i
the practicality of it that is when i
think you would see
a i made i don't know a lot but you'd
see a significant more significantly
more uh opt-outs
if you insisted no matter how you did
the bubble that if you had to be away
from your loved ones for five months
well and i agree with that but but the
point is the supply of willing nfl
players and capable players not that
we're talking about the same highest
level of achievement but there are
plenty of guys out there who can step in
in 1987 the nfl found 28 teams worth of
players on the fly to come in now it
wasn't great football but people watched
it and that's what they would do this
year they'll watch it it's on tv it's
nfl football they'll play fantasy
football they'll gamble etc they'll fill
up the rosters and off they go but you
know though and and i don't know if this
is a fair comparison or not but you've
got members of the military who are gone
for months at a time and they make a
hell of a lot less than what football
players you're right about that
that's a choice
that's a choice that people in the
military make you know oh this is a
choice too for the military
it is but you never ever were told at
the beginning of this profession oh by
the way you've got to be away teams in
the playoffs oh you've got to be away
for six months you can't have any
contact with your family for six months
mike i i understand what you're saying
you're right about that what happens now
if five starting quarterbacks in the nfl
what happens in brian tannehill calls
john robinson and mike gravel and said
i'm sorry i'm not what happens if tom
brady calls bruce arians and jason no i
don't think he's eleven
it's not happening but what about
matthew stafford
you know i mean he's had health issues
in his family you know with his wife
obviously what about kirk cousins
you know who's joe family man and look i
don't know what would happen i truly
don't maybe every quarterback would just
come back bite the bullet and all that
stuff but
i'll i'll be honest with you if d smith
and jc tritter agreed to this i would be
absolutely utterly shocked
and here's the balance though and this
is why i'm bringing it up
without that hard bubble per team if we
agree that a comprehensive bubble like
the nba
isn't practical the hard bubble per team
where guys aren't going home they're not
potentially taking it home and more
importantly not potentially for the team
purposes not bringing it back with them
from a family member from a kid who is
in school or wherever or whatever may
happen
if if
the balance is if you don't do that what
are the chances of getting 256 games in
if you do it what are the chances of
getting 256 games in and look we are
clearly into crystal ball territory and
there's no way to resolve this there's
no way to know
but
i i don't want us to get to a point
despite the fact that some in the media
peter think that we are rooting for
there to be no football i don't want us
to get to a point where the season
implodes upon itself and we say
the nfl says
we should have just done
localized hard bubbles and told these
guys you're gonna be away from your
families for five months and we would
have got these games in we would have
played the season everybody would have
made their money we would have been able
to have a real season with a crown
champion and we would have been able to
show that we can beat this thing and it
would have taken a real sacrifice for
coaches and players but we would have
gotten it done as it stands we weren't
able to get it done because we weren't
willing to tighten the belt and make
that sacrifice i don't want that to
happen i don't want that to be the
regret that people have um but but
understanding what you're saying that
it's going to be a major hardship and it
does change the circumstances it does
change what you signed up for
but
i'd still say a lot of these guys aren't
going to want to walk away from the
money they're not going to want to walk
away a lot of guys
a lot of guys would bite the bullet and
do it there's no question about it i
guess my question is let's say you've
got the top 500
players in the nfl however you would
grade them however you'd rank them
you know let's just say for the sake of
argument you you get you get whatever 15
players a team let's say the key 15 guys
how many guys wouldn't play we've
already seen with the patriots they
probably lost two of their 15 marcus
cannon and dante hightower maybe even
patrick chung is a third
but the giants lost nate soldier the big
question is you know how many of those
500 would walk away
really hurting their teams
i i would bet at least 100 would would
walk away and one of the reasons i think
mike is you and i sit here and say man
what about this money how can you give
up this money
well you know there's been you know i i
think the number if i'm not mistaken
nate solder has made 71 million dollars
playing the sport of pro football you
know i think he can do without whatever
his number is i think it's 13 or
whatever his salary is this year
so i think a lot of these guys would
basically weigh it and say
even if it means i'm not going to play
beyond this year period i'm going to opt
out and i think there's more of those
than you think if you said
for the next five months and this is for
the teams that don't make the playoffs
for the teams that go deep into the
playoffs if you're a kansas city chief
it's not five months away from everybody
it's six
so
again the 49ers probably so that is
where i think you'd really get into some
trouble
the current nfl approach is conducive to
potential outbreaks in part because as
we discussed earlier of the delay
between sample collection and test
result we could have sufficient
outbreaks that could put teams in
position where they aren't able to go on
sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports